and I was any would go to the audience
and the audience would laugh like a
bunch of chained seals and then Dinesh
would say I never said that when you're
having a debate with someone from an
opposing viewpoint it is imperative that
you at least present your opponent
fairly oh really
like what do you want to prison
so and I made this case last week that
so many people were saying I used to be
thin to the Young Turks until it went
off the deep end and so I showed some
clips with my friend Lee Doran and said
no they've always been off the deep end
you've just evolved you've changed and
I've received hundreds maybe thousands
of emails us last week about from both
sides saying no I think that I'm still
relatively liberal I think they went
further off the deep end than I'd like
and then I've received a lot of emails
from people saying you know I think
you're right
I only saw what you posted with Lee
Doran but I'd like to see more going
back you know if that's just an isolated
incident so again we're going to just we
should probably make this an installment
we need an intro on all of it because
I've just got the stuff cat a lot I've
been following it forever
and it's just now that people for
whatever reason can't stand the Young
Turks and then understand what they do
so this goes back it was this Oh 8 it's
oh nine it's old its 309 and this is
them with this is jank with jonah
goldberg back then so you tell me if he
seemed reasonable right back then in
hosting a voice of opposition I
suspected a bit of a political
conversation I went on to jonah goldberg
he's editor at large of the National
Review Online he's a visiting fellow at
the American Enterprise Institute and he
wrote the book liberal fascism the
secret history of the American Left from
Mussolini to politics of meeting a
highly absurd book he's now promoting a
book he's editor for proud to be right
that's also interesting so Jonah one of
the Young Turks thanks thank you very
much I'm assuming you haven't actually
read my book but that's fine
of course not because it has a insane
title like liberal fascism why would I
write a title title so nobody can watch
that I know whether you like Jonah
Goldberg or not I'm not necessarily the
biggest fan I understand that he can be
a little little self-important but yeah
some some good writing out there is it
just me does it seem like he was still
back then kind of an ass kind of an ass
is it just me no I'm gonna go with
definitely an ass definitely now okay
again I think that you just weren't
aware of it a lot of the people who
claim I was young
to expand here's a lot of people woke up
with Dinesh did a national date with Jay
you know and we might get Dinesh on the
show I've worked with him in the past
and and we kind of missed each other but
I really like some of the stuff that the
next doesn't he's a he's a ballsy little
brown man that Dinesh D'Souza and I was
going to actually were talking about
this doing the debate with him and Joe
Heyman and jank if you haven't watched
it I highly recommend you watch Dinesh
and Chang debating because it is it is
it is the perfect example of someone on
the right trying to present arguments
and trying to have an actual thoughtful
discussion of disagreement and Dinesh
whether you like him or not has done
this for a long time with Dawkins with
Hitchens with with I think even Chomsky
possibly Sam Harris and then it happened
with jank and if you if you haven't seen
the debate what's so funny is Robert
went out and Dinesh said who did you
think won the debate and everyone was
saying chanc right after that and
remember chanc tweeting you oh well
you're old people think you lost you
know it's bad well it's not that at all
anymore if you go and look and somehow
it sort of likes this is that the
discussion was pretty much you know
Dinesh would say this is an actual this
is paraphrasing I remember Qiang said so
you know the nice rights to this book
that uh you know all black people should
be grateful for slavery but now because
their parents were slit but now they
have a better because they're in America
how would he black people here right are
happy about slavery anyone of course
they're not happy about slavery right
and I was any would go to the audience
and the audience would laugh like a
bunch of change seals and then Dinesh
would say I never said that when you're
having a debate with someone from an
opposing viewpoint it is imperative that
you at least present your opponent
fairly oh you know this kind of language
and approach is you know of being
abusive toward abuse just like your
ex-wife if you read the divorce
proceedings
no I read your books
everyone launches a young dogs that's
the entire debate at no point does he
answer any of Dinesh's
why is that not incredibly accurate it
is accurate it's just the most
unintelligent conversation but that
wasn't what was it one friend goes
thankful for slavery right delicious big
flavor it was a great internet cuz of
course that's not what I said where'd
you say the slavery is bad what'd you
say what is it will you won't just let
first farmers buy of course it was bad
cuz of course slavery was heinous and is
inexcusable and I've said that many
times what I talked about was this idea
that everybody engaged in slavery across
the world across the entire globe and
people's subsequent generations have
been better off growing up in the orbit
of freedom in the United States oh you
big wall if you want the present yes I
just can't so we try and watch
opposition as much as possible most of
the stuff I read comes from you know
HuffPo salon they all those lights I
just can't I don't know if I can do some
great thought see right there but you go
push the face the Young Turks tough
anymore so this is where we are black
lives matter we talked about it earlier
aiming a rut it is more logical to say
that a woman ain't aiming a loaded rifle
shotgun and a police officer is it
exemplary of systemic racism when she
gets shot it's more reasonable to the
left to simply accuse someone of beating
their ex-wife and pointing out that they
went to prison than it is to actually
debate and argue ideas that's where we
find ourselves in 2016 and I think a lot
of people are waking up to it if you
like this video subscribe or click
what's playing next to me it's taken
from the full show that's right every
week the full two something our podcast
that's never going daily and it's never
going daily stop asking but it's free
you can go watch it play it in your car
it's better than texting and driving